foreign
[Music]
and welcome to the long-awaited
continuation of nariditsky's opening lab
it's been a couple of years since I've
done one of these videos but I've always
planned to continue this series now a
lot of YouTube content is dedicated to
gambits and trappy lines and ways to win
quickly but there isn't a lot of content
on the other side of the coin how do you
actually play against these gambits how
do you refute the Stafford how do you
refute the Danish Gambit and that is
where I come in opening videos for me
are the toughest to make they are the
most ambitious undertaking here we go
I've decided to take the plunge and the
next video in this series is going to be
dedicated to the endglund Gambit which
haunts one D4 players now for many years
it is a very trappy opening it's an
opening that a ton of players don't know
how to play against and there's nothing
more frustrating than knowing that you
can get a huge Advantage but not knowing
how and ultimately falling into some
sort of trap but worry not if you invest
this hour or how long however long this
video will take I promise you that you
will never have a problem against the
endglund gamut again as a one D4 player
so without further Ado let me switch
scenes and we will Plunge in to our
analysis
and one more note before I begin you
might remember this from the previous
opening Lab videos these videos are
meant for serious players who are
willing to invest 45 minutes an hour
maybe a little bit longer in order to
master the way to play against these
openings I'm not really giving you any
quick fixes I'm not giving you any four
move lines I am going really really deep
into the weeds I've tried to be as
comprehensive and thorough as possible
in service of that I've used the leeches
player database to actually look at what
the most common moves are and we will be
going not only through the quote-unquote
main line you might be aware of the
famous Queen sacrifice in the England
Gambit that will be the main line but I
will also show you how to play against
all of the other common responses and
there are quite a few so buckle up feel
free to pause the video at various
points you can set up the position on
your own board you can do some
supplementary analysis this is meant
sort of as a comprehensive analysis but
obviously there's no way that I'm going
to cover every single move and every
single variation but I will do my very
best so first of all what is the England
gamut well in the England white plays D4
and black responds with the move E7 E5
now often this is just a pre-move
mistake where you're expecting one E4
but this is a legitimate opening and it
has picked up in popularity I think over
the last couple of years there have been
quite a few YouTube videos which have
come out and what makes this exciting
for black players is that it is pretty
trappy and if white makes a series of
natural moves black can not only emerge
out of the opening with a decent
position but there is one trap that tons
of players fall into uh and this trap
does involve making a series of
incredibly natural moves what's
hilarious is that we will deliberately
fall into the Trap because you have to
fall into it in order to get a winning
position so the England is named after
Fritz England who was a Swedish this
chess player he wasn't particularly
strong and what's funny is that England
wasn't actually uh didn't actually play
the England what he did is sponsor a
thematic tournament I think around the
1920s where players had to play D4 E5
and ultimately the opening came to be
known as the England game but but the
first player according to my research
who played D4 E5 was George Henry
McKenzie Scottish born one of the
strongest American players of the second
half of the 19th century he played E5 in
1870 and that move was not repeated in
tournament play for another 30 years
Mackenzie ended up winning that game so
pretty impressive how some of those
players in the 1800s were ahead of their
time
so obviously we accept the England the
first step is to take on E5 and before
doing that remember that you shouldn't
pre-move on move one when you play D4
you definitely should not pre-move C4 or
Bishop oh definitely not Bishop F4 uh
because E5 will come as a bit of a cold
shower there you should always expect
your opponent to play C5 or E5 even even
in a bullet game so
after accepting the pawn we reach sort
of our first big Crossroads black has
essentially three or four very popular
moves here the main move by a country
mile is Knight to C6 developing the
Knight to which of course we will
respond Knight F3 the line that's the
subject of most YouTube videos is this
move Queen E7 this will be sort of our
main line we will dedicate the most time
to it but before we get there there are
a couple of other important moves to
consider
first and foremost there is the move F6
and this move is nothing to sneeze at
because if you just sort of blindly
capture the pawn which is fine white is
doing okay there but black will
recapture with the Knight and what you
want to avoid in the England and what I
analyzed with an eye toward avoiding are
positions in which you're giving black
what they want right a big lead in
development potentially the f file it's
very easy to stumble into a practically
unpleasant position right you play
Knight C3 black can already get the
bishop out and then quickly castle and
in a Blitz game this is not a very
practical way to play therefore you meet
F6 with the move E2 E4 an important move
to remember now the idea is pretty
obvious you are indirectly defending the
E5 Pawn I've loaded this move up with
double question marks for obvious
reasons Queen H5 check
simply ends the game in pretty standard
Fashion King E7 Queen E5
it's going to be a quick Checkmate and
if black plays G6 which is incredibly
common uh at least on Lee chess this
position has occurred well over a
thousand times the one thing to remember
is that after Knight F6 your queen isn't
trapped it isn't trapped because black
isn't threatening Bishop G7 and that
gives you a Tempo to bring your Bishop
out and pin the Knight and after Queen
takes E4 check oh you can cover the
check with Bishop to E2 black is a full
Rook down and he's also getting
massacred on the king side Queen takes
G2 the clinical move is actually Bishop
to H6 threatening a Checkmate on f8
black cannot save the bishop and he
simply loses everything so F take C5 is
a huge mistake and for that reason the
only logical move here is Knight C6 now
we follow up with Knight F3 and I love
variations where you essentially
sacrifice back the gambited pawn but at
the end of the day you're the one who's
having all the fun when you're facing a
Gambit player the last thing that they
want is to recoup their investment but
to do so while getting into a miserable
position where they're the ones getting
attacked and that's exactly what happens
here now Knight takes E5 you simply take
and play Queen H5 that's virtually
identical to the immediate F takes C5
black has to recapture with the pawn and
now we bring our Bishop out to C4 you
can almost think of this as a fried
liver where white doesn't have a d-pawn
and black doesn't have an F1 literally
if you added those two punts to the
board it would be an Italian but without
the d-pawn white gets immediate control
over key Central squares the diagonal is
opened whereas without the F Fawn black
is never going to be able to Castle
short the king is going to be stuck in
the center and from a practical
perspective black is virtually lost here
so after Knight F6 you do indeed play
this fried liver Style with Knight G5
there's a cute line if black plays Queen
E7 trying to take the sting out of the
fork then white wins the queen with
Bishop F7 check and then 96 check due to
the pin on the D5 black has to give up a
full queen that ain't gonna cut it so
black can try to play this like a fried
liver right where essentially going down
the main line the chief difference is
that after e takes D5 Knight A5 the move
that I really like here is actually
Bishop back to D3 normally in the fried
liver you give the check on B5 and that
move also leads to an advantage but
Bishop D3 is practically very very
strong now Knight takes D5 runs into the
devastating Queen H5 check so black has
to recapture with the queen and now you
simply castle and it may appear that
black is doing all right here but in
fact his position is completely
crumbling there's no better way to see
that than to follow the line where black
tries to Castle kingside as quickly as
possible after Bishop E7 you bring your
knight out to C3 attacking the queen and
if the queen drops back to D7 there is a
beautiful tactical shot that leads
immediately to a winning position I'd
recommend that you pause the video here
and try to figure this out this is
actually a very very instructive tactic
and I will be back in just a second I
gotta turn the AC on because White's
position is pretty much on fire either
all right hopefully that gave you a time
to think
so the move is Bishop takes H7 and this
is really a a lovely tactical shot it's
quite easy to understand the idea on
Knight takes H7 white delivers a check
on H5 and a check on F7 and what's funny
is that this has occurred once in 2009
and a game in a correspondence game and
white plays Knight takes H a check this
is a classic windmill back to F7 then
take E5 for some unknown reason black
continued playing but uh we will pause
our analysis of this line here so if we
go back to Bishop takes H7 we remind you
that white first castles black develops
the dark squared Bishop you bring the
Knight out and then Bishop takes H7
happens if black takes the queen this is
the sort of second part you have to have
this intermediate move otherwise you
would have lost the bishop then and only
then do you recapture the queen and
white is completely winning Black's
position is in shambles or up upon
Knight F7 is coming and you know the
rest deserves a little commentary
so instead the engine gives the only
move essentially as Bishop to G4 black
has to try to Castle Queen side but this
really doesn't help all that much the
queen is shifted to E1 where it aims
both of the Knight and at the pawn and
after black Castle's Queen side white
brings the Knight out to C3 so White's
play is incredibly natural here and
simply put the queen has nowhere to go
if it goes back to C6 then black walks
into a fork if it goes back to D7 I like
throwing in the move H3 just for a
little bit of lift and after Bishop H5
Queen takes E5 the second reason you
throw in the move H3 is that you have
well you have the F5 Square for the
queen but Queen E6 here leads to a
winning end game for white where we're a
pawn up and we still have a huge
initiative this also actually happened
this was an obscure game between
glembeck and barbolic also 2009 I don't
know what it was about that year that
made correspondence players obsessed
with the England but that essentially
covers the move F6 on move two so app
six whoop that's the end of the line
after F6 we responded with E4 Knight C6
Knight F3 and all you really have to
remember is this right you remember up
to Bishop C4 your next move is going to
be Knight G5 just in order to get into
that lost position black has to make a
bunch of engine moves this is a
miserable position last thing I'll say
is that Bishop B7 walks right into Queen
D5 right this is where the absence of
the D file really helps white and
there's no way to stop Queen F7 this
kind of trap does exist also in certain
Italian wines white wins the game here
so back we go to our second move
deviation we looked at F6 now let's look
at the move that George Henry McKenzie
played who of course was the first
person to play this line and this is a
common move it's the move D6 this might
actually be along with Knight C6 Knight
F3 D6 which this will transpose into
objectively speaking this might be one
of Black's better lines the good news is
that we don't really have to analyze D6
on move two because your response is
going to be Knight to F3 and in this
position black essentially has nothing
better to do than to bring the Knight
out to C6 and this is going to transpose
which means going to reach the same
exact position as we would get after
first Knight C6 and now D6 and just for
the for the sake of organization we will
examine this line through uh the Knight
C6 move order but before we get there
let's complete our examination of the
move to Alternatives the only other
alternative that is even remotely
popular and makes any degree of sense is
the immediate Bishop development to C5
and the funny backstory behind this move
is that it is featured in a series of
YouTube videos I think Eric Rosen gives
this trap I don't remember who was the
originator of this opening trap it's a
hilarious one and the strap happens if
white plays Knight F3 black responds
with D6 and after e takes D6 black plays
the move Knight E7 definitely go watch
that video I think
there's something incredibly satisfying
about watching people walk into these
crazy opening traps and hopefully you
can understand the idea after de7 there
is Bishop takes F2 check and queen takes
D1 and black picks up a full Queen what
I will recommend is a move that
completely circumvents that trap not
that it's a dangerous trap you don't
have to take the Knight on E7 but the
move I prefer is actually Knight to C3
and there is a specific reason that you
develop this Knight first and keep the
other Knight for the time being on G1
and you will understand this reason in
just a moment so if black plays Knight
C6 then once again after Knight F3 we
will transpose into a position that we
are going to examine through the other
move order so D6 is the only way to try
to make this line work and now white
plays the move Bishop F4 this is a very
important idea in the England
essentially anytime black plays D6 your
default is to bring the bishop out to F4
what is the purpose of this move well
it's quite simple first of all you're
trying to provoke black into taking on
E5 and if black does that well we don't
even really need to analyze this
position you now have a pawn up end game
where the king is going to be subject to
an attack after White Castle's Queen
side this is horrendous so D5 is out of
the question but against any other move
such as 97 now you take on D6 and the
point is that black cannot recapture
with the queen black can recapture with
the bishop But ultimately black is going
to be saddled with a tremendously weak
and isolated D6 Pawn needless to say as
a result Black's compensation will be
exactly zero so for example C takes D6
you play E3 then you bring the bishop
out to D3 the Knight to F3 not only does
black have no compensation but even if
material were equal white would still be
better because this Pawn is incredibly
weak and you don't have to worry about
D5 you definitely don't have to worry
about D4 because your pieces are all out
of the gates and obviously here black is
only going to lose the queen to Bishop
takes H7 check and the same thing
happens if black plays your Bishop F4 uh
we were looking at 97 ed6 Bishop D6 this
does not change anything again you take
on D6 and after C takes D6 uh you can
play E3 just like we did in the other
line Bishop D3 and Knight F3 uh and
white is almost winning according to the
engine actually with that extra Center
Pawn so the only other line here that I
uh noticed is Knight C6 in this position
now you can take on D6 but you can also
keep the tension with the Knight F3
remember that D takes E5 is never a
problem because the queen trade is
virtually always in White's favor and
after Bishop G4 now is a good time to
take on D6 oh sorry C takes D6 and again
you know the drill E3 Bishop B2 develop
your pieces naturally I paused the line
here you're gonna Castle uh King side
you're gonna be a healthy Pawn up and
black is going to have no compensation
um so after Bishop C5 the point of
bringing this Knight out first is that
you want to meet D6 with Bishop to F4
and the other bonus is that if blackplay
is 97 you can actually go after the
bishop with Knight to A4 I like this
type of move because it eliminates
Black's only active piece black is
already in huge trouble here there's no
way that the bishop can worm its way out
of the attack here you go c3b4 you bring
the Knight out and now you go C4 and
black is in huge trouble because there's
no good way to prevent C5 and D6 you
always meet with e takes D6 this is
water under the bridge clearly this is
not a particularly serious continuation
for black
so now we go back one more time to the
position after move two so far we have
looked at F6 we have looked at D6 which
will transpose into Knight C6 Knight F3
D6 and we have examined Bishop C5 now
let's get to the real meat of the matter
which happens after Knight C6 Knight F3
and first of all we have to look at D6
which is a very serious alternative
to what I would call
the main line the main line of course
being Queen E7 the recommendation in
most YouTube videos this move was
brought into practice by a Latvian
player named Carl bettens
was kind of a he was a great coffee
house player I think of the early 1900s
he also developed the Latvian Gambit
actually that's why it's called the
Latvian Gambit in honor of Carl betensch
so Queen E7 is the move that you really
have to know backwards and forwards but
we still have to look at D6 here now
your response is going to be and Bishop
F4 is very much possible but even more
powerful is to bring the bishop to G5
and again the idea is almost always the
same you are trying to
get a scenario where after he takes D6
black is forced to recapture with the
pawn you don't want to recapture yet
because this plays right into Black's
hands here you're giving black very
active development but if you throw in
this move Bishop G5 and black plays the
obvious Bishop B7 now after the trade
it's time to take on D6 because again
black has to recapture with the pawn and
once again we get the kind of position
where black has zero compensation for
the pawn I like the engine
recommendation here which is C3 and E3
kind of playing this London system style
creating full control over the D4 square
and immobilizing The d-pawn Bishop's
going to come out to D3 or E2 and queen
B6 can be very comfortably met with
Queen to B3 and after Bishop E6 you
should not worry about the a file being
open because you can just put your Pawn
on A3 where it is protected by its
neighbor on B2 and the engine evaluation
here is around plus two which I think is
reasonable you're gonna bring your
knight out and you cannot ask for
anything more than a pawn up end game
where black has no compensation
so rewinding back to the position after
Bishop G5 there are essentially two
other moves that are more serious than
Bishop E7 there's the move F6 which I
think is the most logical Gambit style
move and there is a surprisingly common
move Queen to D7 and after Queen D7 you
now play e takes D6 you kind of violate
the rule but look at how awkwardly the
queen is placed the bishop cannot
develop the Knight on G8 can't really be
brought out because Knight F6 you'll
immediately snap that Knight off the
board and ruin Black's Pawn structure so
the most common move on leechas here is
F6 I guess in response to F6 you can
just drop your Bishop back to H4 and
this is not scary in the least and if
black brings the Knight out to E7
there's a bunch of things you can do I
think the most practical and I will
analyze this a little bit more deeply
and put this in the PGN file that you
will find in the description but I'm
pretty sure that a simple move like E4
is going to give white a huge Advantage
there isn't much to animal lies here you
can bring the bishop out with check and
drop the other Bishop back to G3 trading
is good for the side that's up material
and in the event of Bishop takes G3 H
takes G3 once again there's absolutely
no compensation to speak of so F6 here
is not very serious Queen F5 is a little
bit more annoying and a little bit more
concrete But ultimately black doesn't
achieve anything because he doesn't have
the requisite pieces developed you call
Black's Bluff here with the move E4 and
I probably analyzed this position for
too long the PGN file will have some of
the other details but suffice it to say
I don't want to bore you to death so in
response to Queen G6 we play the move
Queen to D2 and here I like the idea of
castling Queen side and basically just
going after Black's King Bishop G4 you
bring your own Bishop out to B5 that's
another nice bonus of playing Queen D2
and after Knight E7 there's a cute idea
you play Knight H4
and you essentially Force the queen onto
an awkward square if Queen H5 then you
will play H3 and G4 and win the queen
and after Queen E6 you start expanding
on the king side H3 first we grab the
Knight on C6 with the idea of Knight
takes C6 Knight F5 putting the Knight on
a very powerful Square attacking G7 and
here the simplest is to liquidate with
Knight takes D6 and castles short so I
essentially you don't have to memorize
this because you can play this over the
board and everything gives wet a great
position but in response to Queen F5
it's worth knowing the move E4 and if
Queen G6 we protect the dark squared
Bishop with Queen to D2 preparing to
Castle Queen side if black plays Queen
to A5 the only thing to remember here is
the move A3 you want to stop Bishop B4
related Shenanigans and you're also
preparing in some lines to trap Black's
queen with the move B4 for instance if
black plays Bishop G4 again you bring
the bishop out to B5 and the idea isn't
so much to take the Knight on C6 it's
actually to play the move B4 and trap
Black's queen queen B6 and now pause the
video and see if you can find the
simplest way to complete the queen trap
well the move hopefully you were able to
spot is Bishop back to E3 always be
aware of the power of retreating moves
the queen has nowhere to go and black
loses the game
so back we go to D6 Bishop G5 so we've
looked at Bishop E7 not very serious and
now we've looked at Queen D7 in response
to which you take on D6 and simply
develop your pieces lastly we should
look at F6 and here of course you do
take the pawn and simply develop your
knight to C3 I'm analyzing these lines
for the sake of completeness but real
realistically Black's compensation here
is totally minimal because the Knight on
F3 is going to do a great job of
blocking the f file so even if black
tries to quickly get his King side
pieces out it's not going to be
particularly effective here I like E3
which is a slightly more modest move
than E4 E4 was also very much possible
and here I like the idea once again of
castling Queen side and turning things
back around on black actually going for
black skin so you play Queen D2 and
against almost anything you Castle Queen
side and it's pretty easy to see here
that Black's Queen side attack is no
match for what White's going to do on
the king side I think A6 is natural
white response with H3 forcing the
bishop to make a decision if Bishop F3
you play GF and you're just gonna
Massacre black down the G file and if
the bishop drops back then you play the
natural G4 and the sort of classic King
side expansion with Knight H4 snap the
bishop off the board and uh there's this
is just a complete and total disaster
you can ignore Black's Pawn storm on the
queen side because you always have the
D5 Square for your Bishop this is
completely winning
Black's position collapses so F6 may
seem scary and it may seem like a
concession to open the app file but with
the bishop as actively placed as it is
and with the possibility of Castle in
queenside this is not scary in the least
and there's no compensation to be found
there is one cool little trick that I
want to show you before we move on if
black plays Bishop G4 then I really like
the move Queen to D3 and it's easy to
miss the point of this move after Bishop
E7 we actually take the Knight on F6 and
hopefully you're able to see where this
is going after Bishop F6 Queen E4 check
picks up the bishop on G4 the England is
full of these tricks not just for black
but also for white because white Black's
King is always so weakened in the
absence of the E5 pawn and of course G
takes F6 is the only move but it's all
absolutely miserable after Knight D5 we
don't have to analyze any further so
back we go to Knight F3 the good news is
that F6 doesn't have to be analyzed
because after E4 we transpose back into
a line that we already looked at
remember that we looked at it through
the other move order F6 E4 Knight C6
Knight F3 and hopefully you will recall
that after F takes C5 Bishop C4 this is
like a terrible version of a fried liver
so F6 has no independent value and that
means other than the main move we need
to look at one other line and that is
the move Bishop to C5 and once again
when in doubt you want to develop your
pieces naturally so when in doubt the
move is usually going to be Knight to C3
but here specifically black isn't even
getting out of the gates because if he
goes D6 hopefully we'll also remember
that D6 is usually met with Bishop to F4
posing black a terrible ultimatum e
takes D6 is coming or black can choose a
miserable end game
and after Knight G7 I really like this
move Knight E4 the point is to clamp
down on the D6 Square now black is
unable even to get the light squared
Bishop out without losing another Pawn
furthermore the bishop comes out to G5
and I had a little bit of fun analyzing
this line Knight F6 Jack actually wins
the game this just shows you why you
can't get away with this kind of opening
play with black gf6 Bishop F6 and white
has the completely Unstoppable threat of
Queen D2 Queen H6 and queen G7 Checkmate
and if of course black puts the Knight
on F5 then Queen G5 is going to be the
mating move
so after Knight F6 a g takes F6 is
harakiri but so is King h8 because now
the queen is brought up to D3
threatening checkmate
and after Knight G6 you have Knight
takes H7 and black loses loads of
material here black will lose the
exchange and the game is simply over so
Bishop C5 is a very common move but if
you go Knight C3 black really I would
say is borderline lost here because
either D6 Bishop F4 which we've already
looked at or Knight G7 don't forget this
move Knight E4 clamping down on the D7
Pawn
and finally we have sort of cleared the
Shrubbery and now we will look at the
main move which is Queen E7 we're about
27 minutes in I'm aiming for maybe a 50
minute video or so so we're moving right
along here
hopefully the pace is not too
overwhelming thus far at the end I'm
going to do sort of a tldr summary and
help you understand what you really have
to remember and what ideas you have to
understand so what makes Queen E7 such a
tricky move is that a lot of players
when they look at this position from the
white side they come up with two obvious
candidate moves the first is Bishop F4
to protect the E5 pawn and here they
Waltz into Queen B4 check forking the
bishop and the King now what's hilarious
and this is a side note I don't want to
get too derailed but Jonathan schrance
was a strong player has a good YouTube
channel he analyzes a line where white
goes Knight C3 sacks the bishop and puts
the Knight on D5 and of course wins the
rook and apparently white is borderline
winning here as well but the theory here
gets incredibly complicated I definitely
would point you to his video if you want
to deepen your knowledge of this of this
line but I think the line I'm
recommending is just a little bit more
practical the second thing that a lot of
players do and I'm myself was very
tempted by this when I first started
facing the end blend that's the move
Knight C3 sacking the pawn back and now
Knight D5 and to an untrained eye it may
seem like white is already winning you
know black is gonna lose the Knight on
E5 but actually not black can take on F3
with check
calmly dropped the queen back to d8 and
yes white is better here but the
evaluation is far less clear-cut than it
may appear White's development Advantage
is all well and good but Black's Pawn
structure here is pretty solid and
already you know the Knight is coming
out and White's Knight on D5 is going to
get smoked out and I've lost some games
here with white White's Advantage is not
as large as you might think it is it's
only 0.6 or 0.7 here according to the
engine and so in order to truly refute
Queen E7 we need to go down the main
line and that is the move Bishop to G5
and
this of course walks right into the Trap
it allows black in fact it encourages
black to give the check on B4 and that
is the only serious move there's nothing
else that black can do queen C5 has
happened sometimes on leeches presumably
sometimes this is a mouse lip and
actually it is worth knowing a series of
moves here you do play Knight C3 and in
response to Knight takes C5 you have
this incredibly powerful retreat with
the bishop to E3 right and this isn't
just a computer move the point of this
move is quite straightforward if black
moves the queen you trade on E5 whereas
the bishop going it's going to the
beautiful Center Square on D4 and here
whites develop an advantage and control
of the center is totally decisive black
is just unable to get his pieces out of
their initial squares for instance D6 I
like the modest move Bishop E2 and I
analyze the sample line Knight F6
castles Bishop B7 it almost looks like a
sicilian where white is up like a
thousand Tempe but after black castles
white has this beautiful idea before
sacrificing the pawn getting the Rook
into the game and now what you do is
Chase the queen One More Time and then
bring the other Rook up to after and
just look at the extent of why it's
developing an advantage black is totally
and completely lost and you essentially
pre-move Knight to D5 you play it even
after Bishop G4 because you take the
Knight with check recapture the bishop
and you are completely and totally
winning Bishop takes F6 is coming next
so I really like this idea of 95 Bishop
E3 more common online is Knight takes F3
check but this merely allows you to get
more pieces out and gain the diagonal
for the light squared Bishop Queen B4 I
really like A3 and if black grabs the
pawn after a knight B5 the game is
simply over you're attacking C7 and King
T8 Bishop D4 traps the queen it's
important to avoid the automatic Knight
A4 you might be familiar with this
pattern but here black has the
evacuation route through E5 so you you
want to go Knight B5 in this position
with the double threat of Bishop D4 and
Knight takes C7 Queen E5 you chase the
queen away with F4 and you win The Rook
in the corner so Queen C5 is not a scary
move here it's worth sacrificing back
the pawn for an overwhelming development
Advantage F6 is also played from time to
time I analyze this very deeply I don't
want to devote too much time to this
right now suffice it to say that you
play in the standard way you take on F6
you play Knight C3 and uh you know the
only move that you should be aware of is
Queen B4 which may look a little bit
scary but really it's not you take on F6
ruin black structure and just play the
move Rook B1 right don't be afraid to
make these moves which may not look the
prettiest but they do the job black
doesn't have any pieces in the game and
so by defending B2 you are ensuring that
your queen side is going to be stable
and now you know the drill throw an A3
play E3 and if given the opportunity the
light skirt Bishop is best developed to
B5 with ideas like B4 on the horizon as
well and you can check out the PGN file
for more analysis in the line with F6
but we really need to get down to
business let's roll up our sleeves
because Queen before check is the move
that you have to know the best
so white response with Knight to C3 of
course one of the common traps that a
lot of players fall into is that they
Panic they play Bishop D2 and they think
oh let's smoke the queen out with Bishop
C3 hopefully you already know the black
wins the game with Bishop to B4 a
devastating move pinning the bishop to
the gang and after the trade white loses
the game because Knight takes C2 and
queen takes A1 are both Unstoppable
threats White's going to lose the rook
and then sup but we avoid that with a
10-foot pull and instead we simply
continue our development with Knight to
C3
and only after Queen takes B2 do we
bring the bishop back to D2 of course
you could also start with Bishop D2 but
that move is actually a little bit less
accurate because the queen could move
back to E7 and you could play Bishop C3
here but it's unnecessary to allow any
of this especially because black is
losing in this line black is objectively
lost in the queen takes B2 variation and
the first step is to bring the bishop
back to D2 in order to protect the
Knight on C3 now very importantly if
black plays Knight B4 you meet this with
Knight to D4 and black just doesn't have
enough meat on the bone here after C5
you have the intermediate move Rook B1
forcing the queen away now Knight B5 is
totally crushing Queen A5 A3 and
oftentimes what you will see is that
White's development Advantage here is so
overwhelming that the position I hate
this phrase but the position really does
play itself a lot of times and of course
your main idea is to combine threats
against the queen with the idea of
forking the rook and the King on C7 this
is really basic Betty but first of all
don't be afraid of night before and
remember the move Knight to D4 so
obligatory for black is the move Bishop
to B4 and this is the lead up to uh the
sort of Hamilton variation I think we
should name it after Ramon because he
has played this line a lot with black he
has developed some of the theory and
it's definitely a dangerous practical
weapon if white is not prepared
so white plays the move Rook to B1 this
is natural you attack the queen and here
black reaches the most important
Crossroads of the variation Queen to A3
is the move that most players go play if
they're not sort of familiar with the
theory and we will address this
separately after Queen A3 Knight D5
white reaches an absolutely overwhelming
initiative in the center and this is a
line that you really don't even have to
know all that well as long as you
understand the general schema of White's
development you will quickly see that
Black's position to say that it is
miserable is to say nothing black is
totally lost in this variation I did a
lot of analysis here I'm going to cover
all the bases but the line that you
really want to know is Queen takes C3
and after Bishop C3 Bishop C3 Knight D2
black acquires two minor pieces for the
queen and it may seem like black also
has a raging initiative and after Knight
takes C5 there's the threat of Knight C4
as it turns out Knight takes C5 I don't
want to say it loses immediately but it
does lead by force to a completely lost
position so I guess it does but it's
very important after Knight takes E5 to
not procrastinate and to immediately
immediately chased the bishop out of C3
with Rook B3 this is the first important
idea of this line Knight C4 doesn't work
anymore you take the bishop the bishop
has nowhere good to go if it goes back
to D4 you keep chasing it with E3 and
now I like the pretty looking move Queen
to A1 pinning the Knight to the G7 Pawn
after F6 Black's initiative has been
completely repelled and when you've
reached that point where there are no
longer any direct threats against your
king you can simply continue your
development with Bishop E2 then you will
Castle short and a good move to throw in
is A4 trying to drive the spawn up to A5
here Black's compensation is totally
limited and after D6 F4 black is simply
going to lose the G7 Pawn so Bishop D4
is not serious much more common is
Bishop A5 and once again our old friend
Queen A1
arrives at the scene here after Knight
C4 you simply take on G7 completely
ignoring Black's measly you know play
with the minor pieces black is nothing
developed in the move Rook B5 ends all
of the fun party's over because you're
gonna take the bishop no matter what
black does Knight F3 check of course you
play King D1 and there is nothing left
to analyze you're gonna take the rook in
the corner and be completely winning
so this is all total BS
if black plays F6 then we play Rook B5
again trying to get rid of this bishop
force it onto another diagonal in the
event of the trade this is a completely
winning position for black I analyzed
this further in the PGN but not much to
talk about here Black's compensation is
absolutely minimal and after Rook B5 if
black plays Knight C4 this is the only
other important idea we sacked The
Exchange on A5 and you will see this
idea happen several times don't be
afraid to sacrifice in exchange for
blacks dark squared Bishop because this
rids black of his only active piece
Queen C3 Forks the knight in the pawn
and after Knight C6 there is a
devastating follow-up move that simply
ends the game let's see if you can pause
the video and Spot It
okay well the move is Queen 2g3
especially when your opponent is not
developed like this you want to pay
attention to all of the undefended Pawns
that often leads you directly into the
the correct move Queen G3 Forks of Pawns
and wins the game
so what we've been analyzing is the move
Knight takes E5 to which we respond Rook
V3 we looked at Bishop D4 and Bishop A5
is met with Queen to A1 and lastly if
black plays D6 we force the Knight out
of E5 with the move F4 and you know the
drill once again you play Queen 6 G7
nothing has changed here Knight D2 Rook
B5 or Bishop D2 King D1 and uh Black's
position collapses after King E7 I
wouldn't even take the Rook here I would
play the move E4 immediately addressing
the Knight on C4 and you can get to The
Rook later you're gonna take on C4 and
threaten F7 and Bishop G4 is not
possible because you can take on G4
technically black can go like this but
When the Smoke Clears white plays Bishop
C4 and Black's position is totally in
shambles so Knight takes E5 is the more
popular move in the Lee chess player
database but I would I wouldn't call it
a mistake the mistake is to play the
first move E5 but after Rook B3 black is
simply losing and I I didn't really even
find a single way to complicate the game
needless to say if black trades well
this makes it even easier for for white
and don't forget that the queen often
belongs on the long diagonal in this
line because you're going to be
threatening F4 and if you can put it on
C3 then you're also threatening C7 so
this is
not very serious but let's get to the
move that Amman plays which is Bishop
takes C5 this is a far more serious line
now let's take stock for a second black
has two minor pieces and a pawn for the
queen and if you really want to deepen
your understanding of this position you
can take a look at you can plug this
into chess base or or the leeches
database and take a look at some of
amman's games in this line if white
plays this too passively then what often
tends to happen is that black gets the
minor pieces out Knight F6 and D5 and
ultimately Black's position is
incredibly solid there are no weaknesses
in Black's position the pawn structure
is very much intact and Amman actually
played this in a classical game against
the strong player Stephen zerk and I
think he made a draw I'm not sure how
the game ended but it's worth looking at
the game that will really put into
perspective how important it is here for
white to play aggressively so the first
step is to play the move E3 opening up
the bishop but the critical position
comes after Knight F6 six this is where
I've come up with a novelty that I think
puts this line completely out of
commission if you're looking at this for
the first time you might be playing
Bishop E2 or Bishop D3 is why better in
those positions absolutely but in order
to really win the game quickly you want
to play the move G4 and maybe double X
Glam is overstating it a little bit but
I really want to emphasize how important
this move is to remember because it
takes this line again completely out of
commission the idea of G4 is twofold of
course you're preparing to feed and
ghetto your Bishop onto the most active
square but more importantly you're also
preparing to steamroll Black on the king
side with G5 and F4 and maybe even H4
and H5 for goodness sake you're up a
queen let's use that and what better way
to exploit that than in the context of
an attack so let's take a look at a
couple of moves here
if black ignores with castles you can
play G5 but first I would bring the
bishop out to G2 because G5 isn't going
anywhere and after D6 the lines here are
very straightforward G5 F4 building the
pawn chain and after Bishop C3 you
simply castle and pre-move Knight E4 for
instance Knight c594 and once minor
pieces start getting traded I mean black
can essentially resign here G6 might be
forced because after rookie 8 there is
Queen D3 with a fork on the bishop on
the pawn and after G6 you just play H4
you attack rookie 8 Queen D3 and H5 and
black is busto here he can't move the
bishop because we've got the B file H6
is coming in F5 to follow this is plus a
million and there's not much left to
analyze here
so rewinding rewinding if black castles
you start with Bishop G2 if black tries
the more ambitious move D5 once again
you play G5 this leads nowhere 94 does
nothing you just take twice and you're
never afraid of this series of empty
checks because the King has a perfectly
serviceable Square on G1 Queen H5 is the
threat that will Fork the bishop in the
pawn
so after castles Bishop G2 I really
don't even see a move for black H6 does
prevent G5 but guess what obviously you
play H4 and this makes the threat of G5
even more powerful so that's not an
option D6 I think might be the only way
for black to Stave off defeat I analyzed
a couple of other moves in the PGN but
just in the interest of time we're going
to accelerate the process just a little
bit because you do the same stuff in
every line here you play G5 if Knight D7
Bishop G2 then F4 then you castle and
Knight E4 we've been there before and if
Knight D5 you play the important
prophylactic move Rook to B3 taking the
sting out of the move Knight to C3 if
black plays it anyway which he probably
should because black doesn't have much
else to do black castles then you can
chase the Knight with C4
and F4 is actually going to trap the
bishop if the Knight moves back to B6
Knight C3 you play Queen C1 and after
Bishop E6 you have the very powerful F4
and simply at the end of the line the
dark squared Bishop is trapped that is
the sort of third idea of playing that
initial G4 move not only is this Pawn
chain imposing in and of itself but it
also often traps the bishop on E5 Knight
A2 you can play Queen to B1 Knight to C3
and now Queen to A1 is very precise
because the Knight has no discoveries
and if night before then just Bishop D3
defending the pawn and ultimately black
and procrastinate but he will ultimately
lose the dark scored Bishop
okay so let's rewind back to the
position after G4 the only other thing
that I want to emphasize is the move D5
to which you again respond G5 and again
any trades of minor pieces is going to
be good for white Bishop G2 is going to
come with great effect then you tucked
your king away black is ultimately going
to lose all of his pawns B7 E4 those
pawns are going to start falling in
Queen E2 Queen C4 here is a great
maneuver and so that move the move G4
really does put this line out of
commission just to reiterate 95 you go
Rook B3 if Bishop B5 you start with E3
now I looked at a couple of other moves
here although Knight F6 is almost always
played D5 you strike at the center
immediately with C4 and this only plays
into White's hands after D4 you can play
Knight F3 and obviously you jump at the
opportunity to grab that dark squirt
Bishop you don't care about giving up an
additional Pawn moreover you get the
e-file here so this this is just a
complete and total disaster
so that's not very serious Knight G7 I
also looked at but really you have to
remember is the move G4 and again the
PGN has even more extensive analysis I
also looked at the move H6 but you
essentially get the same type of game in
every line white plays Bishop G2 then F4
G5 and in every one of those cases black
is just totally lost so the queen
sacrifice it's a cool Line Credit to
Amman for really playing this in an OTB
game that was gutsy but if you know the
move G4 and you know the idea of Rook B3
and queen A1 you are not gonna have any
problems winning the game there and that
leads us to our final variation which is
Queen 2a3
and on Queen A3 we respond with the move
Knight to D5 this is actually an
important thing to remember because a
lot of players automatically play Rook
B3 it's a very tempting move but the
queen can drop back to A5 I know Levy
had a video here where he won some games
with the black pieces if you play
nonchalantly you're gonna give black a
chance to bring the king side out and
castle and maybe you're even gonna lose
E5 white can still make this line work
but much more effective is the immediate
Knight to D5 now black has two options
here most players are going to take on
D2 but Bishop A5 is a slightly trickier
move that might be the Lesser evil
although black is losing everywhere so
let's start with Bishop A5 here
you follow up with the move E4 and I
think the most important thing to
remember about this line where black
plays Queen A3 is that you don't need to
do anything extraordinary with white all
you really have to do is bring your
pieces out you're in no hurry because
black is unable to untangle in the
center your your Center is so stable
with the Knight supported by the pawn
that you can afford to complete your
king side development and once you do
that then you can get down to the
business of either trapping Black's
queen or if black is able to Castle
kingside going after Black's King so how
does that actually unfold well Knight G7
is pretty standard white responds with a
very modest Bishop E2 now you're never
afraid of the night trade on D5 because
these pawns are going to tear black two
shreds after 97 it's a good time to play
Rook B3 and now this is very instructive
just Castle you just Castle right
because
black takes on D5 and this is all very
very one-sided everywhere you have some
way to win either the queen or a minor
or a minor piece
so you should trust in the power of your
pieces here but what I really like is
after castles white has the beautiful
Bishop C1 I love these types of
retreating moves the threat is obvious
you're preparing Rook A3 and you're also
removing the tension so the queen has to
move back to A4 and now look at what we
do we start chasing the Queen Boom boom
boom boom every move of tempo F5 is the
only move now we take on passant and we
drop our Knight into G5
threatening H7 how can black play
without the queen side developed right
this is a totally losing proposition for
black to begin with there are a lot of
really cool lines for example G6 D6 is
really pretty then a check on C4 and
once the king moves you skewer sorry you
pin the queen with Bishop two B2 so all
of this is tremendously one-sided Knight
G6 you also can play D6 with virtually
the same idea you can find more analysis
here in the PGN but suffice it to say
that here after Bishop E2 castles
castles Black's position is in total
shambles or sorry after castles we were
looking at the move
let's see so just to clarify we were
looking just now at the move Knight
takes D5 yeah we were considering the
immediate Knight D5 to which you respond
Rook B3 then you castle and then you
have This brilliant move Bishop to C1 so
what happens if black does not take on
D5 if black castles well when in doubt
just continue developing your pieces and
black just has no way to untangle here a
couple of sample lines if Knight G6 then
again you play Rook B3 Queen C5 Rook B5
drops actually Queen C5 Bishop E3 loses
the queen so Queen takes A2 is forced
and again it's time for Bishop C1 this
time it's even more powerful because
black will simply lose the queen queen
A4 we play the com Bishop to D3 setting
up the Unstoppable threat of Rook A3
Knight takes E5 trade Rook A3 and black
will lose more than a minor piece
because Queen C6 gets forked with Knight
to E7
so as we rewind back to the position
after Castle short Rook B3 really is the
main idea in this position followed by
Bishop C1 if black tries to beat white
to the punch no problem right if black
takes first and then plays Knight G6 the
simplest is again to play Rook B3 and
after Queen takes A2 it's time for
tactics it's time for a typical idea
that we've already seen once in a
completely different line but anytime
you have a Pawn on E5 a knight on D5 and
a queen on D2 those are the ingredients
of a lobster pincer mate that you can
put into effect with Knight F6 check
after King h8 Knight G5 black gets
crushed there's a beautiful line where
you sack another Knight but it's all
very easy to follow Rook H3 and queen H6
is simply Checkmate and if black plays G
takes F6 then after e takes F6 Queen H6
followed by Knight G5 is completely and
utterly Unstoppable the root cause of
all of this is one and the same it's
always the same it's the fact that black
has no Queen side development and you
cannot play a serious game of chess when
half of your pieces are still on their
initial squares and so that means that
Bishop A5 might be the trickier move but
you respond in very straightforward
fashion E4 Bishop E2 castles and then
Rook B3 is going to happen inevitably
with either a play against Black's queen
or a tactic on the king side again more
details in the PGN and you are more than
welcome to dig around here on your own
in fact I would really recommend that if
you want to deepen your understanding of
this position
because you might be looking at this and
saying well I kind of get that white is
doing well but it you know it can be
hard to understand the extent of White's
Advantage unless you're really really
well acquainted with how this position
works but hopefully you found that
helpful and finally Bishop takes D2
check is much more common you recapture
with the queen and remember that Queen
takes A2 is completely water under the
bridge you could not care less about
that move you always meet it with Rook
D1 building the battery against the D7
pawn and black runs into the same
problem every time which is that there
is no good way to defend the C7 Pawn the
only way to defend it and the only move
is King to d8 a lot of people only just
play Knight G7 just take and take the
rook and win the game
after King d8 you might be tempted by
the move Queen G5 check and it's
actually less convincing than it appears
because it helps black develop their
pieces instead much better is to play in
once again the most modest possible
fashion you play E4 and again just
Bishop B2 develop your king side because
black is totally and completely
paralyzed that's the beauty of this
position we already know that this is
never scary here it's even less scary
because white drives the pawn down to D6
and then the check on G5 is going to be
completely devastating
and if black tries to trade Queens you
say no no no C3
and once again Knight G6 now it's time
for a check on G5
just castle kingside and it's just such
a one-sided position for instance after
C6 97 97 Queen G7 picks up all of the
kingside pawns and Knight G5 is coming
in one leeches game continued H6 the
queen dropped back to G3 after Knight D5
85 Queen C3 let's see if you can find a
really pretty move that ends the game on
the spot white found it in the game
well the move is Knight to G5 opening up
an attack on Black's Queen but the the
pretty detail is that here we grab F7
and we take with the F Pawn protecting
the Knight and we follow up with Bishop
H5 with devastating threats against
black skin again look at Black's Queen
side it still hasn't been developed no
matter what black tries He's just never
gonna be able to push that d-pawn out to
D6 okay
so let's rewind for a second back to
Queen takes D2 right if black plays the
immediate King d8 that doesn't change
all that much in fact after E4 Knight G7
it gives white the additional move
Bishop C4 this is an even more active
move than Bishop E2 and after Queen C5
now we drop the bishop back to E2 why
did we lure the queen to C5 well you
already know this concept now we bring
the Rook up to P5 and again you reach a
position you don't know what to do when
in doubt just castle kingside and it's
going to work itself out Knight takes D5
you can take back with the Rook after A6
Rook B3 we just pounce with Knight G5
and E6 and this is a complete and utter
Massacre some of these lines are really
really fun I had a great time analyzing
this obviously here you can drop the
Knight back and pick up the queen on A2
essentially the rule is you can do no
wrong in this position right if you're
making natural developing moves they're
most likely going to be some of the best
moves that you can play and ultimately
once you have brought your Bishop out
and castled kingside then you should
switch your attention to the king side
and you should be looking at Knight G5
and at Queen G5 check and you should
always be keeping an eye on Black's
Queen and making sure that there isn't a
direct way to trap the queen
okay so what else did I look at I also
looked at Rook B8 but you can acquaint
yourself with this and the PGN here you
drop the Knight back and this is one of
the only lines where white is okay with
the queen trade and the reason why is
that you now have this massive clamp on
the D6 Square white is actually
completely winning here G4 is a computer
move but I like the idea of bringing the
Rook into the game via G1 and G3 black
is totally busto 97 again you're always
checking Knight G5 and there's a kind of
funny idea where you can take on H7 and
bring the Knight back and only then you
can play the move E6 or you could play
it immediately but if you want to be
clinical remember that Rook f8 can
usually be met with Knight H7 and then
Knight back to G5
okay
so just to recap because I know that
there's a lot of moving Parts here after
Knight D5 we looked at Bishop A5 to
which you responded for and now we
looked at Bishop takes D2 check Queen
takes D2 the most common move on Lee
chess is Queen takes C2 so you are very
likely to get this position and if you
get this position then King d8 is
virtually forced after E4 as long as you
remember that the key is to develop your
king side and then either put the queen
or the Knight on G5 you are good to go
and again there are more details in the
PGN file between A5 you always meet with
C3 so you keep the Queens on the board
at all costs and that ladies and
gentlemen I think largely concludes the
line with Queen A3 so just to recap
let's go one more time from the
beginning and then I will kind of
summarize uh the key points as a whole
but the main line
continuous Knight C6 Knight F3 Queen E7
Bishop G5 quote unquote walking into the
trap now we avoid Bishop D2 and Bishop
C3 we instead play Knight C3 bring our
Bishop back night before you play Knight
to D4 and after Bishop B4 we say Bring
It On sack the queen we looked at the
queen sack and after Queen A3 you avoid
the tempting Rook B3 instead you
centralize your knight immediately
if black plays Bishop A5 and keeps the
tension we say bring it on e4 and Bishop
E2 and although black is able to Castle
Rook B3 is going to come with absolutely
devastating in fact we looked at Knight
G6 Rook B3 and now remember the idea of
retreating the bishop to C1 this
literally will win you a couple of games
if you Hammer this idea home in your
mind remember Queen A4 Bishop to D3 no
rush setting up the queen trap
and we also looked at the more popular
move which is the immediate trade on D2
followed by either Queen takes A2 or
King d8 it doesn't change much White's
strategy is the same you always play E4
then you can play Bishop C4 if given the
opportunity if not you can develop
modestly to E2 then you castle and then
either Knight G5 or queen G5 is going to
be totally winning if black plays H6
here
and for example plays I don't know B6
here already you're trapping the queen
right so here here it's like the third
idea you're always looking for this
concept but if black plays Queen A5 yeah
you can't get your queen to G5 but the
point is to get your queen to the king
side in general
and in a position like this again when
in doubt I analyze these positions a lot
with the engine the engine always gives
these sort of slow improving moves enjoy
yourself here right have fun look at
this position black can't move a muscle
and the only other idea that you should
keep in mind is that when the Knight
lands on G6 you can chase it away with
H4 and H5 and if black plays H5
themselves then you get the G5 Square
for either your queen or your knight
so let's not belabor the point here
hopefully I've explained this line
fairly clearly and that means it's time
for us to summarize we're right on an
hour so a little bit longer than I
intended but if you're still watching
you're still taking notes thank you very
much I know these are very technical
videos but again if you put in that time
you are going to be rewarded 100 fold
because you're actually going to enjoy
your experience of playing and aren't
going to be stumbling in the same
openings so the England Gambit E5 we
accept it black has two general ways to
play Black and play with one of the
pawns or black can play the main line
with Knight C6 and queen E7 if black
plays F6 we do the fried liver thing and
play E4 Knight F3 and Bishop C4 if black
plays D6 then we play Knight F3 and
after Knight C6 we transpose into the
Knight C6 Knight F3 D6
uh Bishop C5 you avoid the Rosen Trap by
playing Knight to C3 and remember D6 is
almost always met automatically with
Bishop F4 intending to take on D6 and
ruin Black's Pawn structure after Knight
C6 Knight F3 D6 here you've got a bit of
an exception Bishop F4 by the way is
also totally possible here uh but black
has this tricky line where he goes like
Bishop G4 and then Ed Queen F6 that is
why here I recommend Bishop G5 and this
puts black in a very unpleasant
ultimatum if Bishop B7 you trade and
take D6 if Queen D7 again trade and
develop naturally and if F6 trade and
develop naturally that is the
commonality in all of these D6
variations you accept the pawn and you
bring your pieces out to active squares
E3 Bishop C4 and remember you don't have
to Castle kingside oftentimes you can
Castle Queen side and go after Black's
king with a an H Pawn storm
so that brought us to well Bishop C5 we
also looked at there you just play
Knight C3 this brings us to the main
line
we play Bishop G5 falling into the Trap
remember Queen C5 Knight C3 95 and now
one retreating move Bishop B3 seems like
that's one of the sub themes is like
retreating moves with the bishop we have
Bishop E3 and then we've got Bishop D2
to C1 in the main line
and if black plays Queen before this is
what you will get most of the time the
key thing to remember is Queen a395 and
in the event of the queen trap you've
got two lines if Knight takes E5 we
don't procrastinate we get rid of the
bishop and remember Queen D1 to A1
followed by F4 and taking on G7 if F6 we
play Rook B5 and the secondary idea we
sack The Rook for either the bishop or
in the event of Bishop B6 we of course
sack it for the Knight this wins on the
spot and that's about it with Knight
takes E5 Bishop takes E5 is the more
serious move and hopefully I will be
checking the chess.com database to see
who discovered this novelty I'm pretty
sure G4 has been played a couple times
on leeches but nonetheless if you
Uncorked this move and you play
instantly you'll you'll feel like a boss
so the move G4 puts this line out of
commission because it creates too many
threats you want to go G5 and F4 you
want to develop your light squared
Bishop to G2 and you do it in that order
first you typically bring your Bishop to
G2 then you go G5 unless of course black
plays D6 then you go G5 immediately use
your judgment Knight T5 Rook B3 here is
pretty important if black instead
castles then you have the time to
develop the bishop first H6 always met
with H4 and ultimately you're going to
go G5 and F4 drive down the pawn chain
castle and position the Knight on e4
Black's compensation is well at this
point there's just no compensation black
can't move a single muscle
and finally we looked at
uh the move Queen A3 to which you
respond Knight D5 Bishop A5 E4 the two
key ideas here develop your king side
pieces and then I guess three ideas look
for infiltrations with Queen F4 and ig5
remember Bishop C1 that retreating move
and always make sure that you're uh
looking out of your peripheral vision at
Black's Queen because sometimes you can
simply trap the queen especially after
you castle with Rook A1 and Rook H to B1
and as I've been hinting at there is a
complete and comprehensive PGN in the
description it has some text annotation
so if you're feeling overwhelmed right
now worry not because you can review the
PGN at your leisure and remember the key
is nobody remembers every single move in
the opening as long as you have a
general understanding of the main ideas
and most importantly why you play the
moves what is the Zen of these ideas
then you are going to be essentially set
for life hopefully I've been relatively
comprehensive if I've left something out
I apologize for that but uh you can
always leave a note in the comments and
I will try to address any variations
that I haven't gone through in this
analysis promptly and on that note
ladies and gentlemen it's been over an
hour thank you so much for watching you
know these videos are a labor of love
hour long videos don't do all that well
on YouTube but you know to those who are
really in it for improvement you know
this community is amazing and I just
love the feeling of helping people
improve tangibly doing something that I
know will result in Improvement so thank
you to everybody for the wholesomeness
and the support and these videos will
continue we'll talk about the Danish
Gambit in the next opening Lab video and
on that note I will see you guys soon
happy refuting the England bye
[Music]